10-класник Володимир дуже любить бігати центром Києва
і слухати музику, часто німецьких виконавців.
Та, що саме вони співають, до кінця хлопець не розумів,
але завжди хотів дізнатися.
І ось раптом натрапив на мотиваційний плакат,
присвячений україно-німецькому року мов.
Вивчіть перші 10 німецьких фраз просто зараз
– під час прогулянки або пробіжки парком.
Для цього треба зробити наступний крок.
Хлопецьнамагається це вимовити.
Від одного плаката до іншого.
Такий собі квест німецькою парком Шевченка.
Якщо є сумніви в правильності вимови,
є коректор - робот з Гугл-перекладача.
Бігай і вчи німецьку.
Це те, що дуже подобається хлопцю.
Адже про вивчення німецької він мріє вже рік.
Коли з батьками був у Німеччині,
мені там дуже сподобалися люди.
І я зрозумів, що треба вчити німецьку.
В школі у хлопця німецької немає. Лише англійська,
яка аж ніяк не схожа на німецьку.
Якось в мене англійською виходить!
Володимир вирішив звернутися до першоджерела –
німецького Ґете-Інституту. Він єодним з організаторів
країнсько-німецького року мов та вже 25 років працює в Україні.
Хлопець у захваті від бібліотеки інституту.
Тут є геть усе. Аудіо, відео, книжки.
Курси для початківців, професіоналів, дорослих та дітей.
Володимир вирішив спробувати це на собі.
Розминка закінчена. Тепер на черзі
урок у дитячому цифровому університеті.
Це спеціальний онлайн-проект Ґете-Інститутудля дітей, безкоштовний.
Він допомагає пізнавати різні сфери науки
і в ігровій формі знайомить їх з німецькою.
Цього разу діти дізнаються, звідкіля у мушлі шум.
Разом з Крістофом Біманом -телеведучим популярної
вже 30 років в ФРН дитячої програми «Передача з Мишкою».
Цей університет – не єдина віртуальна цікавинка,
що з’явилася в Україні цьогоріч у межах українсько-німецького року мов.
Приміром, оця. Ви прокидаєтесь велетенською комахою
і бачите світ її очима, як герой Кафки Грегор Замза.
Це розробка празького відділення Ґете-Інституту.
Занурення у найвідоміше оповіданняФранца Кафки «Перевтілення».
В Ґете-Інституті задоволені тим, що їхні креативні ідеї
у межах україно-німецького року мов мають резонанс.
Україна, за даними інституту, нині посідає п’яте місце всвіті
за кількістю тих, хто вивчає німецьку.
Тут вивчають німецьку715 тисяч молодих людей та дорослих.
Інтерес великий в Україні.
І тому наше гасло: «Зроби наступний крок!»
Тобто, використай свої знання німецької.
Зроби наступний крок і вдоскональ свої знання.
Отримай сертифікат щодо завершення навчання
і збільш свої шанси на кращу кар’єру з німецькою.
Володимир теж зробив черговий наступний крок.
До ще однієї своєї мрії.
Він хоче спробувати здобути в Німеччині медичну освіту.
І такий курс -спеціально для медпрацівників - в інституті теж є.
Але спочатку треба вдосконалити елементарну німецьку.
Ти зможеш! Хлопець в це вірить.
Тому хоче записатися на дистанційний курс з вивчення німецької.
Це ще одна новація Ґете - Інституту.